pour les neuf en tmp on voulait
absolument refaire une séquence culte
s'il en pense quoi ton frère alors je
vous dis camille on a demandé à camille
le leur faire ou de venir nous voir
aujourd'hui n'a pas pu puisque tf1 l'on
empêche malheureusement
valérie avait trouvé en norvège vous
c'est vous qui l'aviez exactement alors
c'est une séquence que j'avais trouvé en
norvège je vous le dis voilà et je
l'avais proposé à camille jaillit ça
serait bien que tu le fasses voilà donc
c'est vrai que cette séquence nous
appartient en fait voilà on a on l'a
achetée à la norvège sachy le trait on a
acheté cette séquence est vrai qu elle
parce que tout le monde croit que c'est
une séquence voilà qu'on avait que
camille avait trouvé mais camille le
faisait hyper bien et je me suis dit
comme camille n'est pas là eh ben je
vais m'y coller et j'ai fait du il en
pense quoi ton frère et je peux vous
dire bravo à camille parce que rester
dans un camion pendant tout attendre des
passants c'est une bonne kallas donc
bravo à lui
regardez que c'est parti
[Musique]
quelles seraient vos idées pour limiter
la pollution de paris la première chose
ce serait pas de voiture du tout donc
des voitures électriques ce serait
vraiment top
et faire en sorte que les vélos puissent
être beaucoup plus facilement accessible
pour tout le monde et faciliter les
mouvements tout simplement pas de
voiture d'essence ni gasoil que l'équipe
ils en pensent quoi vous offrir mon
frère oui votre frère lui et tuto dans
les avions c'est encore pire c'est par
finale du mondial turc
pnc aux fortes s'il vous plaît notre
commandant les compagnies on y va et
décollage immédiat vers le bonheur
la camarde la pollution là jusqu'au bout
et on peut même pas fumer nos petits
tranquille rappaz le corps plus à pied
les vélos les trottinettes qui a et on
limite en fait les voitures intra muros
elle en pense quoi votre soeur ma soeur
moi je bats à celle là
on se bat revient à l'état une soirée
soirée rouge ça lui lèche ou là des
choses des éclairages du poussin léger
la consommation ça peu près tout ce qui
me vient là ils en pensent quoi on
serait mon frère toujours qu'aucun taux
longs sans déconner on y va on a l'eau
sacca dans la poudre d'histoire-géo
lourds doit vous laisser moins des moins
des trafics plus de transports en commun
votre soeur elle en pense quoi mais
qu'elle sert cf comment il veut ah bah
je sais pas il sais pas qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
très bien alors quelles seraient vos
idées pour limiter la pollution à paris
elle limite est tout simplement l'accès
des voitures sauf celles qui font la
livraison ou les riverains et elle en
pense quoi votre soeur ma soeur habite à
moscou dont vous jouez le jeu celui-ci
joue doux ou de nouveau brillé pour le
jour loulou jour joue pas au bout bien
sûr prendre le vélo
et puis trottinette électrique donc l'or
là trois choix bons et transports en
commun bien sûr mais après il faut
vraiment essayer de bonjour vous allez
shekels coiffeur
je suis en taille and dye je fais envie
d'en parler tu sais j'ai eu des gros
soucis capillaire me suis fait rouler
dessus par une trottinette justement on
a roulé sur les mais voilà on va
préférer marché alors donc là comme ça
au moins il y aura pas de problème
quelles sont vos idées pour limiter la
pollution dans la capitale
pour moi on est moi tout d'abord aux
feuilles plus d'attention de
des changements ne voulais pas qu à
jeter les mégots dans le roux après une
cigarette
les papiers les capter coué pour le café
tout ça il y a suffi cendres les
les poubelles ils en pensent quoi votre
frère
mon frère e
je pense je pense que oui là où on en
est mort du loup pour lucio laisse ma
drogue jamais bon d'ouvrir les jumeaux
tu comme dépôt des toits de cagnes où
des pauses mis un que comprennent à
drinking allé battre pour toi pêcheurs
il a dit c'est pour moi la prendre à
brink est mon ami herbert est clair vive
la france fait pas mal me désole
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et merci
c'est à tous les passants
[Applaudissements]